as an entrepreneur you have to watch out
what consumes your time and make sure
you don't get sucked in the projects
that bring you down hold you back and
chew up your time so you can't focus on
the bigger things to grow your business
hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today mason question from one of my
youtube viewers rosu min we too much
here youtube viewers dorky baby dorki
baby anyway dorky baby wrote in
commenting on a video that i had i made
a video not too long ago saying i was
getting rid of most of my books so most
of my books i'm just giving them away I
felt guilty at the start for not reading
them but then figured out you know what
I haven't read these books I haven't
gone back to them better just you know
declutter get rid of them get them out
of my life when I save the seven books
that I love the most and kept him on my
shelf so dorky baby wrote in to say this
video was so helpful for me I had the
same problem with books did you ever
contemplate selling them I'm stuck
between giving them away or selling any
advice Evan this one was an easy one for
me I wasn't even thinking about selling
them mostly because it's not worth my
time you have to value your time as an
entrepreneur it's the most precious
resource that you have and for me to go
off and list my books on craigslist ebay
wherever put up flyers I don't know how
I would sell them it's not worth my time
how much money could i make from these
books compared to how much time it's
going to take me the only reason i would
do something would be as a passion
project why do i go rip sticking or
snowboard in there camping because i
love doing it it's not part of my money
making activities if i wanted to sell
the books as a challenge as something
fun to do is something that got kicks
out of then maybe was worth my time but
just as a way to make money it's not
even close I'd much rather give them
away just get them out of here I'm
having my friends come over there
picking up the books i'm already down
the half of my collection and the rest
i'm going to donate to the local library
you have to make sure that you're
focusing on the right projects for your
business and I know what you're thinking
hey I can make a little extra money why
not do this
I put all this money into these books
why shouldn't get a little bit out of it
it's small thinking it's small thinking
about how much money you've already put
in and how much little money you can get
out of it because you're going to have
to put so much time into it to make it
all happen now if you can make one phone
call on some of them come in and buy all
your books you've got a steep discount
maybe put the go off and try to sell
these things individually it's way too
much work it's not worth the amount of
money that you're going to get coming
back in you'll probably be working for
less than minimum wage trying to sell
these things it's not worth it you have
to spend your time on the projects that
will really help grow your business if
this is something that you're trying to
do to make money there's way better uses
of your time or least there should be to
make money don't get distracted by side
projects and it's not just selling books
is anything entrepreneurs have a little
bit of entrepreneur a DD we like jumping
on new projects we like tackling new
things we get excited by the new even if
it doesn't make us money and we don't
focus on the things that could actually
explode on us that could skyrocket our
businesses to new heights so you have to
be very careful over how you spend your
time you have to be careful about how
you let other people spend your time I
don't answer my phone calls I don't even
know my phone number on the cell phone I
don't know what the number is to this
phone I don't let people waste my time
and I don't waste my own time either so
hopefully that helps those are you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below and hey I want to
hear you have to think please leave a
comment under this video it makes me
want to do more videos for you and it
really is the best part of my day when I
wake up but I check my youtube comments
and there's lots of positive things
being said so please leave a comment or
ask me a question about your business
that be happy to answer it thank you
guys so much and I'll see you on the
next episode
you